♪ ♪
>> Sean: BIDEN TRIES TO PLAY
ON A TOUGH GUY WITH PUTIN,
DONALD TRUMP LAID OUT THE
DANGERS OF YOUR STUPENDOUS ON
RUSSIAN OIL.
OF COURSE, THEY ARE LACK OF
PAYING FAIR SHARE TO NATO AND
THE DANGERS OF EUROPE WILLING
MAKE RUSSIA RICH AND PUTIN RICH
AGAIN, TAKE A LOOK.
>> ENERGY IS A MUCH DIFFERENT
STORY THAN NORMAL TRADE.
YOU HAVE A COUNTRY LIKE POLAND
WHO WILL NOT ACCEPT GAS.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
COUNTRIES, THEY WON'T ACCEPT IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
CAPTIVE TO RUSSIA.
GERMANY, AS FAR AS I AM
CONCERNED, IS CAPTIVE TO RUSH
BECAUSE IT IS GETTING SO MUCH
PUBLIC ENERGY FROM RUSSIA.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT
GERMANY BUT GETTING THEIR ENERGY
FROM RUSSIA.
EXPLAINED THAT PURITY CAN'T BE
EXPLAINED, YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Sean: FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAR IN CHINA IS
ABSOLUTELY GOING AFTER TAIWAN TO
PURSUE REUNIFICATION AMIDST THE
EIGHT FOREIGN POLICY MISSED
THAT.
HERE WITH REACTION, YOU CAN SEE
SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO
DONALD TRUMP, FORMER PRESS
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
WE PLAYED 5 MINUTES OF THAT.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE WAS IN THE
FACE OF THE HEAD OF NATO AND
LAYING OUT THE STRONGEST CASE I
HAVE EVER HEARD OF WHY IN GOD'S
NAME ARE WE PAYING THE BULK OF
MONEY TO PROTECT EVERY ONE OF
OUR ALLIED COUNTRIES, EVERY NATO
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE PAYING FAR LESS THAN WE
ARE EVEN AS A PERCENTAGE OF GDP
PAY.
WE ARE PAYING IT TO PROTECT THEM
FROM RUSSIA.
THEY ARE MAKING RUSSIA AND PUTIN
RICH AGAIN.
NOW, I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR A LONG
TIME.
I THINK YOU WERE THE ONLY OTHER
PERSON BESIDES DONALD TRUMP THAT
WAS COMFORTABLE WITH THE ENTIRE
CONVERSATION.
>> SEAN COME I REMEMBER IT WELL.
I WAS INCREDIBLY COMFORTABLE.
THIS IS WHAT FRIENDS DO FOR
FRIENDS, YOU TELL THE TRUTH.
YOU SPEAK THE REALITY.
YOU DON'T LIVE IN A FANTASY LAND
AND PRETEND IT IS OKAY.
DO NOT SEND AMERICAN KIDS TO
FIGHT AN AMERICAN DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT YOU IF YOU ARE NOT
PREPARED TO DO IT.
THAT IS WHAT HE SPOKE TO THE
EUROPEANS HOW THEY ENTIRE TRIP
AND NOT JUST THAT MORNING
BREAKFAST, AS I REMEMBER BUT THE
ENTIRE TIME WE WERE THERE.
WE WANTED EUROPE TO STAND UP TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
WE WILL SUPPORT YOU BUT YOU HAVE
TO TAKE THE LEAD.
THIS IS YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS
IN THE FIRST INSTANCE.
WE ALSO UNDERSTOOD YOU HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN NORD STREAM 2 SO WE
SANCTIONED IT.
YOU COULDN'T LET GERMANY SUFFER
BY BEING DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA
GUEST.
WE CAN SEE THE RESULTS NOW.
PUTIN COMES IN ANALOGS
NORD STREAM 2 PIPELINE TO BE
COMPLETED.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THAT WE ARE
SEEING THE RESULTS ON THE GROUND
AND SOUTHEAST UKRAINE THAT WE
CONSIDER TODAY.
>> Sean: BE CLEAR THAT YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREVENT OF THE
WAVE OF THOSE NORD STREAM 2.
WE HAVE HEARD SIMILAR LANGUAGE
FROM PUTIN AS IT RELATES TO THE
BALTICS.
IN 2014, HE ANNEXED CRIMEA.
WE SEE THE POSSIBILITY OF
POTENTIAL MILITARY ACTION AND
ACTIVITIES GOING ON IN BELARUS.
YOU TELL ME.
IS THIS GOING TO TAKE ALL OF
UKRAINE OR THE TERRITORY AND
PATIENTS OF PUTIN TO TAKE OVER
UKRAINE AND WHERE TO BE GO FROM
THERE?
>> Sean: SEAN, IT DEPENDS ON
THE WEST.
IT IS NOT PREDETERMINED AND NOT
INEVITABLE IT WILL HAPPEN
BECAUSE OF THE GOOD WORK THE
PRESIDENT DID AND IT DID NOT
HAPPEN ON OUR WATCH BUT THE ONLY
THING EXCHANGE, VLADIMIR PUTIN
DIDN'T CHANGE BUT AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP CHANGED.
WHETHER CRIMEA, BUT THE OTHER
PLACE PUTIN IS TAKING LITTLE
CHUNG DIMMICK CHUNKS OF
SOVEREIGN NATIONS IT WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN IF THE
UNITED STATES ON ITS BACK FOOT.
THE SANCTIONS I HAVE SEEN SO
FAR, ONE OF THE SANCTIONS WAS
ALREADY UNDER SANCTIONS, SEAN.
I PROMISE YOU PUTIN'S ALL THAT
AND WHAT HE REASONED IS GREEN
LIGHT.
THESE FOLKS WILL NOT TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY.
AND THIS IMPACTS PEOPLE WE WILL
HAVE HIGHER GASOLINE PRICES
BECAUSE THEY SHUT DOWN AIR
ENERGY AND RUSSIA WILL MAKE A
FORTUNE OF HIGH GAS PRICES.
THIS IS BAD FOR AMERICANS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO GET
BACK IN FRONT OF THIS
REESTABLISHED DETERRENCE AND
DEMAND FOR EUROPEAN PARTNERS DO
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
>> Sean: THE LAST TIME YOU
WERE ON THIS PROGRAM, I ASKED
YOU IF YOU AGREED WITH ME THAT
THE THREE AREAS IN THE WORLD WE
HAVE GOT TO WATCH IS RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE AND CHINA AND TAIWAN.
YOU ARE HEADED TO TAIWAN.
I WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT
AND THEN, OBVIOUSLY, IRAN.
THE OLYMPICS ARE OVER AND I
WOULD IMAGINE AFTER WATCHING AND
LISTENING TO THE RHETORIC OF
CHINA TALKING ABOUT
REUNIFICATION, THAT IS NOT
REUNIFICATION.
THAT IS TAKING OVER A SOVEREIGN
NATION.
FLYING THERE FIGHTER JETS OVER
TAIWAN AIRSPACE.
THE CRACKDOWN IN HONG KONG,
COVID-19, THOUGH UIGHURS BEING
OPPRESSED, ET CETERA.
ANYTHING JOE WAS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO TO STOP THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE FROM TAKING OVER TAIWAN?
I DON'T SEE WHAT HE COULD
POSSIBLY DO.
>> AMERICA HAS THE TOOLS.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SUPPORT
THE TAIWANESE PEOPLE.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY CAN.
WE DID IT FOR 14 YEARS AND
EXACTLY WHAT LEPERS THEY ARE.
ACT DIMMICK ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH DIPLOMATIC SUPPORT.
THAT IS WHY I'M GOING AND I WANT
THEM TO KNOW MANY AMERICANS WANT
THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN TO CONTINUE
TO LIVE THE LIFE THEY HAVE LIVED
AND NOT BE UNDER THE JACKBOOTED
OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
HE HAS THE TOOLS, SEAN.
IT IS SIMPLY NOT CLEAR IF
PREPARED TO ENGAGE IN THE WORLD
THAT PROTECTS THE THINGS THAT
MATTER THE MOST TO AMERICA AND
THE COUNTRIES ALL AROUND THE
WORLD APPEARED FOR SO LONG THAT
I HAVE LOOKED TO US FOR THE
BEACON OF FREEDOM.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM USED THEM
BUT I PRAY THAT THEY BEGAN TO DO
SO.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS UNHOLY ALLIANCE THAT HAS
EMERGED, RUSSIA, CHINA AND IRAN?
IT SEEMS RUSSIA AND CHINA ARE
HELPING IRAN IN PURSUIT OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
DO YOU SEE THE SAME THING?
>> I DO.
AS YOU GO THROUGH THAT LIST OF
COUNTRIES, SEAN, I HAVE BEEN
SANCTIONED BY TWO OF THOSE AND
LaTOYA AS WELL.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
VERY MANY FRIENDS IN THE WORLD.
BUT IF WE ARE WEAK, COUNTRIES IN
THE MIDDLE EAST WE WILL GROW
CLOSER TO THEM AND
SOUTHEAST ASIA WILL NOT FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN PUSH BACK AGAINST
CHINA.
THEY DON'T NEED OUR SOLDIERS AND
WHAT THEY WANT IS THE
UNITED STATES HAS WITH THEM.
WE ARE FRIENDS AND WANT TO
ENGAGE IN COMMERCE WE WILL BE
ALONGSIDE YOU.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
CONFIDENCE THE UNITED STATES
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL DO
THAT.
FOR THAT REASON, THIS ACTS
BETWEEN CHINA, IRAN WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW AND MAKE MORE
AND MORE FRIENDS THE WEAKER THAT
WE ARE.
>> Sean: IF WE CAN WORK IT
OUT.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU FROM
TAIWAN.
THIS IS PIVOTAL.
THE TERRITORIAL